what does it mean to be alive what does
it mean to be human it's a hell of a
topic for a video it's also a hell of a
topic for a game too but I want you to
think about that for a moment
what is the difference between a human
and a robot is it the body the voice if
it even has one or both
if someone sounds human and you believe
they're human are they actually human
could they just be a robot does it even
matter to you if they are what about
being alive most people draw the line at
the heartbeat if the heartbeats were
alive if it doesn't we're dead simple
well not quite what about life support a
variety of medical procedures that are
designed to keep someone alive if the
thing they're being kept Alive by is
making their heartbeat then by
definition they are alive but what is
the definition of Being Alive Now
philosophy is known to make very
straightforward questions more
complicated than they seem but I do want
you to think about this going forward as
Soma was created to chip away at these
ideas and make you question everything
about them Soma is a game about the
horrors of transhumanism existentialism
and what it means to be human I want to
issue a spoiler warning because Soma is
a different game Soma's gameplay is
based around walking running and hiding
there's no weapons abilities skill trees
or side quests it's one of those games
that you buy for the story and by
discussing that story in its entirety I
will have ruined any reason for you to
buy it so if anything so far from the
visuals to the commentary sounds
interesting to you then I recommend you
buy the game play it and come back I can
wait for those of you that want to
continue though let's get started Soma
starts with a brief dream of our
protagonist Simon he's talking with a
girl named Ashley before noticing that
he is bleeding to which he wakes up soon
after this reoccurring dream that he's
having is tied to his phone call this
phone calls from my doctor munchie who
wants Simon to come in for a brain scan
once Simon hangs up for free to explore
his room and uncover the real truth one
day in April of 2015 Simon and Ashley
were driving when a distracted driver
ran a red light and hit their car Ashley
died right away but Simon had permanent
brain damage Simon is now going to see
Dr munchie for her brain skin with the
hope that it will save his life as
without his help he has months at best
one thing you'll notice right away is
how detailed Simon's room is and how
interactive the environment is soma is
one of those games where you can pretty
much pick up anything you want the
objective for now though is to find the
bottle the doctor gave him drink it then
go to the office but there is no time
limit time has essentially stopped
giving us the chance to look at
everything we want this intro is very
reminiscent of Praise intro and both
serve the same purpose they not only
give the player a chance to test
settings and make sure the controls feel
alright but once you actually start
looking around you'll get a glimpse of
the person's life is like Simon at this
moment is just a guy who almost died in
a car accident but Simon is also a
photographer and an employee at a
bookstore judging for the posters in his
room he seems to enjoy music festivals
has an appreciation for art and might
even be into space but not everything is
going to come with a positive outlook
there is trash left on tables and chairs
his fridge is filled with TV dinners and
fast food their various pizza boxes
taking up space around the apartment
there's a plant that seems to have
withered away a bit and he still has the
torn newspaper article reporting on the
crash all these environmental details
provide knowledge to the player about
who Simon is it's only been a few
minutes and already we feel connected to
our character and if anything we should
be he's our protagonist after all so we
should probably get to know him first
before we set off on our journey
together Simon then takes the Tracer
fluid and sets off to Dr munchy's office
although I use Office Loosely as just
like his work it's still in its infancy
Dr Mucci isn't just some normal doctor
and this isn't just a normal appointment
so
what exactly are we doing
we're going to do a scan of your brain
then we build a computer model of it and
bombard it with stimuli
the program will help us to quickly
iterate your treatment plan until it's
fully optimized in short develop the
perfect treatment for your condition the
treatment is called a neurograph and
it's still very much in its early stages
but at this point what does Simon have
to lose if he fails oh well he was dead
anyway but if it succeeds not only is
this a breakthrough for modern medicine
but Simon could actually live so Simon
sits in the seat and Begins the
examination
about as much as getting your picture
taken Indian stock cameras would steal
their souls
what happened
hello
Mr munchie did something go wrong
Simon is somewhere this review Works in
two ways both of which lead to the same
result as a player you either think that
Simon was teleported to a whole new
location or this is just one of the many
simulations that Dr munchie was going to
be doing the latter is incorrect but
it's still an acceptable Theory Simon is
currently in a facility called pathos 2
but there are a lot more things going on
than just a change in scenery Simon can
not only listen to these devices without
touching them but the facility is
underwater Oh and yeah it's also 2104 so
Simon is now 90 or so years in the
future to make matters worse this is a
horror game after all so we aren't the
only beings here but if I'm being honest
Soma's story is a lot scarier than its
gameplay a horror game like Outlast is a
nice comparison Outlast is a scary game
but its story really isn't yeah the main
character is stuck in an asylum but it's
just the character not us the player
Soma's Story transcends the limits of
the game World half the time it felt
like the dialogue was supposed to be for
me and not Simon sometimes Simon would
even just talk to himself about his
current predicament and I couldn't help
but feel like he was talking to me the
game's story is scary but in a way that
gets the player scared as well for
example here's Simon's first interaction
with life on pathos 2.
[Applause]
hey can you hear me
[Applause]
I need it
why
that was okay
what the [ __ ] was that
so much happened in just a short amount
of time I don't even know where to begin
firstly we have a talking robot that is
showing clear signs of sentience which
is already weird enough but it was also
connected to the control panel with
these black tendrils that acted as a
sort of Life Force for it Soma however
knows how to balance it scary with its
soothing elements as right after turning
on the power Simon will get a call from
a woman named Catherine she's the first
person that Simon has been able to talk
to which gives him a large degree of
hope that he isn't alone she also gives
us and Simon our first objective find
the com Center and call her the player
then has to go down another Florida
cross the room but the game feels that
now would be a suitable time for some
actual gameplay this is our first horror
sequence and like many games that have
no offensive capabilities the idea is
the same hide and don't get caught it's
not a difficult sequence by any means in
fact I would say Soma isn't really all
that difficult at all I never died once
during my entire playthrough this is
because Soma has a mechanic that allows
you to take another hit before you die
so while I was caught a few times I
never actually failed except this one
time a bit later when an anglerfish was
chasing me which kind of makes me a
little sad when I think about it as out
of all the robotic and flesh-eating
monsters this game has an anglerfish was
the one thing that almost did me in but
in a bizarre twist that I never saw
coming Soma has a second difficulty
called safe mode it eliminates a lot of
the horror from this game as enemies
cannot kill you unlike a normal mode so
Soma is already cutting away even more
content from an already cut game Soma
has no engaging gameplay in the
traditional sense so all that's left is
horror and story but now the horror is
gone so all there is is just the story
but how can you make a horror game
without the horror well the tension and
stress are still present even in safe
mode but this mode allows the player to
focus Less on the horror and more on the
story and as I said many have argued
that Soma's story is scarier than the
actual horror itself I played this game
on normal for the first time since I
figured the game would lose its appeal
if I played it the other way but there
was one detail about this that I had
naively overlooked from a more General
perspective this is really convenient
for those who have anxiety when it comes
to stressful situations so it's an
accessibility tool but it also doubles
as a story mode the one thing I hate
about not just Soma but games like it
are those specific horror sequences you
know the ones I'm talking about when
you're in a room filled with lore and
info but because there's an unkillable
enemy in the same room you can't find
the time to actually explore the area
and learn the story because you end up
becoming more focused on the gameplay
rather than the story well with safe
mode I was able to explore the areas to
my heart's content and wouldn't you
believe it I discovered things I didn't
find my first time through furthermore
thanks to another setting that removes
the visual Distortion when an enemy is
nearby we can actually see the creatures
that we were too busy running away from
honestly playing around in this mode
made me realize how much of a Ned
positive this ends up becoming for
everybody now should every horror game
include something like this probably not
but I can think of a few games that
would definitely benefit from it using
safe mode we can get a better look at
the enemy in front of us it doesn't
provide us with much info but we can see
it's an amalgamation of tech and flesh
this creature looks similar to the robot
we met earlier but this one is actually
mobile this time once you outmaneuver
the robot we can meet with another one
of those sentient robots from earlier
but this interaction is even more
concerning
[Applause]
are you
hey sweetie
[Music]
I no actually well thanks for being so
helpful
or anything
are you human
did my body give it away I try a hard
saving mystery yeah I'm human are you
now things are becoming more confusing
this robot here named Carl seems
convinced that he is human but we can
clearly see this isn't the case but he
doesn't seem to be joking though he was
a bit sarcastic but who wouldn't be in
this situation if someone walked up to
you and asked if you were human wouldn't
you think they're crazy now a question
has settled in is Carl telling the truth
or is he delusional at the moment it
seems like it can go either way but this
ends up tipping towards delusional as
Carl the guy the robot claims to be is
actually dead down the hall so how can
Carl be dead but also be this robot it
just doesn't make any sense so clearly
this is just some sort of AI or sentient
machine that is mimicking Carl but that
doesn't explain how it was able to
converse with us so fluently the
decision to place a robot Carl in the
same room as human Carl was a genius
Choice as it forces the player to
confront what's going on it's not like
earlier when the robot was just a thing
that existed there is clearly a person
named Carl and a robot who believes he's
Carl at the very least we can assume
that this thing's brain is Playing
Tricks on him but he's not the only
character in this game whose brain is
tricking them only robots Crazy Ones
except for one I think he said his name
was Carl
he was okay but I'm
I'm pretty sure I accidentally killed
him by turning off the power
well
you know robots don't feel anything so
yeah
what was that
whoa what's going on I think this place
is about to collapse what do I do
what the hell
how is this possible
[Music]
this isn't
this is insane
the brain is a very odd organ it has the
ability to store Decades of memories and
information but it also just removes
things when it deems it necessary this
same thing is happening to Simon his
brain is not recognizing parts of him
that exist from Simon's perspective he
sat in a chair and woke up in an
underwater facility his brain was so
confused by the change in scenery that
it couldn't even see that his body had
changed Simon assumed that he was just
wearing the same clothes as before but
it was only until his brain was
confronted with the truth that it needed
to recognize the truth Simon's brain
removed this from its memory in its
Vision because if it wouldn't have he
would have likely gone insane so it
removed these parts of its memory until
it couldn't any longer and it had to
come to terms of the fact that Simon was
breathing underwater had this not
occurred at all Simon would still
believe he was in regular civilian
clothing as he had not been put in a
situation where his mind needed to be
questioned this also relates back to
Carl his brain sees a humanoid body two
arms two legs and all the other parts in
between but we see the real Carl his
brain is sectioning that part of his
existence away because if the truth was
revealed to him Carl would likely go and
say he said his last memory was him
piloting a robot and then the next thing
he knows he was knocked out underneath
some wiring both Simon and Carl have
this Gap in their memory which is why
their brain acts like everything was as
it was before despite that not being the
case it was also mentioned in this
conversation that the power switch Simon
flipped which is something we did a bit
earlier killed Carl but Catherine says
it's no big deal he was just a robot but
was he though the robot trying to kill
us earlier was a robot but is he just as
similar as Carl is Carl really a robot
before the room flooded though we got
our last bit of information that creates
the mold of this story in 2103 about a
year or so before Simon arrived here in
pathos 2 a comet hit the earth and
killed everyone on the surface the only
humans left on the planet that we know
of are the crew of pathos too because
they were below sea level the impact
didn't affect them but given how little
Personnel exists down here the human
race is officially doomed there's no way
to repopulate and even if they all
agreed to do so the Earth is still on
fire so nowhere except pathos 2 is
habitable hell not even in this place is
in stable condition as for why Simon got
sent down here we'll have to come back
to this later but this reveal once again
reinforces a lot of emotions that we've
felt up until now talking with Catherine
felt comforting because she was the only
human we've been able to chat with here
in pathos 2 but since no one has left
she might just not be the only human in
pathos too but the only human in the
world as humans we desire human
connection some people need it more than
others but being alone for extended
periods of time can create a problem for
a person mentally even if you don't
leave your house that much you can still
talk with those who live with you or at
the very least you can text someone or
maybe chat a line through Discord or
something but for Simon none of that is
possible he might truly be alone in this
world and knowing that no one is alive
makes him feel even lonelier than before
which is why Catherine is such a beacon
of light for Simon and the player but to
get to her though Simon will have to
navigate the ocean floor now I don't
have a fear of water but I'd be lying if
I said looking down towards the bottom
of the ocean doesn't at least make me
uncomfortable I can't imagine how it
would feel to be this far down only with
your thoughts but once again the team
behind Soma knows this and sides that
give the player a little robot helper he
doesn't speak and it won't interact with
us but its presence is just comforting
yeah it's a robot and not a human but
it's not trying to kill us which is a
first plus it's kind of cute it's a
little round robot that beeps when it
opens doors what's not to love about it
Simon will eventually make it to a
shuttle station that can take him right
to Lambda where Catherine is located but
the power is out and this brings us to
one of the many choices in Soma
hey are you don't hurt me
remember when I talked about life
support and if that means that we're
alive how about now does Amy look alive
to you in a literal sense yeah but she's
being kept Alive by wires and in her
case is not allowed to die Amy's also
not as lucky as others hooked up to a
ventilator turning off her power will
likely be painful to her but at least
it's quick but should you kill her is
the real question she instructs us to
find someone that can help her but will
we even find them we're never gonna come
back to this location again so this is
our only chance to make a decision using
the limited knowledge we have of this
situation should you grant her death
because no one deserves to go on like
this or should you let her be as there
might be still hope that she can make it
it's the same predicament family members
may have to go through when a loved one
is in a coma or on life support should
we end their life and stop their
suffering or should we just keep going
just a little longer it's a tough
question and one I hope I never have to
answer
the shuttle Simon gets on is about to
crash but in a moment before that
happens we can watch a presentation of
pathos 2 that gives us a bit of the
history of the facility around 2060 the
facility was built as a thermal Mining
facility but now it's become the home to
the Omega Space Gun which is used to
shoot satellites and probes into space
Simon will eventually make it to the
building Catherine is in but is jumped
by this thing it's got the same color
palette as the previous robot we saw
earlier but this one is more agile and
looks different so it seems like these
enemies are one and the same but we
still don't understand how or why they
were created this also highlights
something rather interesting about Soma
it's a small detail but when attacked
Simon will limp and you can see the
camera Bob with his movement which I
thought was a nice touch this also is
not a one-time thing for this event
happens anytime Simon is attacked the
problem though is that the bobbing in
visual effects could give you a headache
after a while thankfully there are
healing stations across the facility but
it's that black goo that we've been
seeing everywhere after escaping its
grasp we can lock the door behind us and
finally get to meet Catherine there you
are upgrading everything
no not you too
I was really hoping you were human
don't let the circuitry fool you I was
human once can't take any more this is
everything's [ __ ] I give up there's
nothing left calm down it's not the end
of the world you sure it sure is how it
looks like it for all I know there's no
one left except for me what do you mean
I'm right here don't take this the wrong
way but I meant any humans left except
for me
have you looked at yourself lately
you're a walking talking diving suit
with some Electronics left on for good
measure I don't you don't want to think
about it we'll start thinking about it I
don't want to do this anymore I don't
want to be this I want out so Catherine
and Simon are robots I didn't believe
the first robot or Carl were human but I
believe that Catherine was because she
had a picture of herself she's
technically the first human thing we met
I saw her face in the com Center and
that was more than enough to convince me
that she was human my brain didn't even
question whether what I was thinking was
even true I just went with it it's kind
of impressive how just a simple picture
tricked me into thinking that the person
I was talking to was different from
everyone else I had met up until this
point Catherine wants us to take out her
cortex chip and put in the Omni tool
that we found earlier on pathos 2. this
gives us a chance to take her with us on
our adventure and also gives her a
chance to explain what's going on while
most of the details are still unknown we
are given our next and final objective
after the comet hit the planet and
killed everyone pathos 2 went down as
normal but obviously their work was
irrelevant to the grand scheme of things
it was mostly just to stay sane and keep
busy Catherine however had a project she
was working on it was something called
The Ark it's a digital space that allows
these copies of people she has to live
on in a virtual world it was a cool idea
at first but since the end of the world
came in when it became a bit more
important these digital copies she has
are brain scans we'll eventually learn
this a lot later in a future area but
after some time Dr munchie continued
with the brain scan science and it
became incredibly successful while his
original idea of using it to help
patients didn't work it did become quite
popular in the fields of AI since Simon
was one of the first people involved in
these brain scans his scan lived on as a
legacy skin one of the original works of
brain scanning pathos 2 has similar
chairs to Dr munchie which they call
Pilot seats and since they have the
Legacy scan of Simon that's why he
suddenly was revived 100 years in the
future in that same area we can listen
to a few audio recordings dated back as
far as 2015. apparently Simon was
actually just scanned like normal and
carried on with his entire day but the
scan ended up not working Simon would
eventually pass away a month later but
before dying Dr munchie asked if he
could use his brain scan for future work
which Simon agreed to that's why Simon's
brain scan is still accessible and since
pathos 2 has some pilot seats and
artificial intelligence which I'll get
to later it explains why pathos 2 has
these scans specifically as for why
Simon doesn't remember the day he died
what's actually quite simple it's like
reverting a previous save his save point
was when he got the brain scan then he
carried on until he died without getting
another save so technically his last
save was the day he went to munchy's
office that's why the intro makes it
seem like Simon went from one place to
another instantly Catherine is also just
a brain scan just a previous version of
Catherine or for to use the same example
a previous save of Catherine what's
unclear though is if her real self is
still alive when Simon goes across the
hall he discovers a few details about
the arc a survey the location of the arc
and a few interviews there are only
three interviews that we can access
Robin Ian and Mark all of them seem to
be very enthusiastic about the arc but
Mark's reaction is a bit different he
says the arc can help the human race go
through the reality of continuity
keep all these people in mind as this
will be relevant later within these
files there's also some pictures of the
arc and we can see what it looks like
inside and it does seem like this
perfect Ideal World before we leave
though we can also take a survey that
people aboard the ark will have to take
once they arrive just like the
characters though I'll bring up the
significance of this later after using
the scanner we discovered that the arc
is still on pathos 2 which Catherine is
very displeased about the plan was to
launch it into space so the arc could
last thousands of years as right now
it's only going to last a few decades as
for why the arc didn't actually make it
into space once again it'll be relevant
later but now we have our final
objective take Catherine to the ark and
launch it this could sound a bit
confusing since the world is gone but
that's the point what else are you gonna
do sulk around and feel sad why not do
some good before you pass on even if it
really won't matter anyway since the
world is gone and the human race will be
extinct more than that though Simon also
thinks that if they can get the arc and
get a brain scan of each other they can
live inside the ark like all the people
are living in it right now to get to the
arc though we're gonna need a couple
items a power suit and a vehicle called
the dunbat on the map are two locations
called Tau and Phi both of them are
thousands of meters deeper in the Ocean
than we already are and due to the
immense pressure build that occurs
around that level the dunbat and the
power suit are the only way to make sure
that we won't go down there without
dying to the pressure Theta is the
closest location to them and it's also
where the done bet is conveniently
located on the way there the two run
into more of that black goo and
Catherine says it belongs to the wow the
wow is the AI of pathos too there's a
lot of information about the wow so
allow me to summarize it for you as I
said the wow is an AI it's located in a
place called Alpha site it's still
within the grounds of the facility but
only three crew members actually know of
its location the wow was held in this
sphere at one point and was injected
with that black goo that goo is called
structure gel structure gel has some
interesting properties to it as it can
repair both organic and synthetic
material you can use it as a replacement
for thermal paste when using a computer
chip and the structure gel is what keeps
people alive it used to be used as a way
to patch up holes around the facility
that the wow would take care of but
after the comet hit its directive
changed its main goal was no longer to
keep the system comes up and running
within pathos 2 but to preserve human
life however the wow was an AI not a
human so it doesn't understand the
nuances of being alive Amy and Carl are
victims of the wow As We Know Carl was
killed but since Catherine had his brain
scanned for the ark the wow used it and
put him into a robot and to believe that
it was saving him it's also how Simon
managed to get into the diving Sioux
body that he's currently in the wow also
ended up creating the various enemies
that attacked Simon throughout the
facility each one though seems to have a
different reason for attacking that
robot in the beginning just seems to be
hostile to anything but this other
creature we met only attacked Catherine
when she was using the building systems
and is now attacking Simon when he tries
to release the brake hatches on a nearby
boat it seems like the wow was creating
a defensive Army to protect himself
which will make more sense once we get
deeper into the facility it is also
entirely possible that it just tried to
create things to preserve human life but
they had negative effects that the wow
had not anticipated because some of the
details about some of these enemies say
that the electrical currents that they
have is what is killing Simon not the
fact that they're trying to kill him
intentionally it's just a a byproduct of
them getting close to him the two then
managed to get to Theta but are stuck to
continue Simon needs another cortex chip
located in another robot but the only
two near us are the helper bot we found
earlier and another rambling machine
similar to Carl we have to zap one of
them until they stop moving so we can
take the chip this is yet again another
choice for the player do we destroy the
helper bot or the robot I mean they're
both robots it shouldn't matter but one
is talking and the other isn't and the
bigger robot is someone like Carl a
person who thinks they're human but is
stuck in a simulation thanks to their
brain regardless of who you choose you
can then take the cortex chip to
Catherine and then go to Theta on the
way there the two end up talking quite a
bit about Simon's current condition now
that he has the time to really think it
through even though Simon has accepted
he is a robot he's surprisingly unfazed
for the most part for as much as Simon's
brain wants to kill him thanks to the
car crash it's also incredibly resilient
it knows it's a robot but instead of
freaking out it has come to terms with
its new environment I think one reason
his brain hasn't imploded yet over this
discovery is the fact that Simon is
still humanoid Carl was not even close
to human but Simon at least looks
humanoid which is something the mind is
familiar with so despite the change it
still feels comfortable near the
entrance to Theta is another robot this
is Robin the same one from the interview
no we haven't met before is this park
I think we're safe
I was so worried something had gone
wrong
what's your name
beta field service technician nice to
meet you Robin
how did you get here
I got scammed like the others
and then I killed myself at least I
think so I can't remember that part how
does that work did dying get you into
the ark wow you're definitely not from
Theta let me guess Comic-Con
wasn't sure Catherine will be able to
scan you guys
you're lucky there was a lot of talk
about this at Theta
the idea is when you're activated in Arc
there's basically two of you right one
human one living skin in the arc you
don't want your coffee to survive you
you yourself want to survive on the ark
if the human you dies before the scan is
initiated or closely after you yourself
would live on an ark
amazing right just like many of the
characters we have met before her you
can choose to kill her or not I want to
brush past that though as what she said
is extremely important if you remember
from the interview the third person was
a mark Sarang out of all the interviews
he had the oddest one whereas the other
two were talking about the arc and their
thoughts on it Mark went on this rant
about the continuity of Consciousness
Mark's theory is exactly what Robin said
if you kill yourself during the scan or
right after then the copied you won't be
on the arc but the real you will be
there instead the brain scans and how
they work are incredibly important the
brain scans copy the person not transfer
them if we use Simon as an example the
original Simon known as Simon one was
the one in Toronto getting the brain
scan the Simon on pathos 2 the one we
now play as is Simon two Simon wasn't
transferred from one body to the next he
was copied into another body so there
would be two Simons at this point if he
wasn't copied 90 years later this causes
is a lot of problems for Catherine as
people were constantly killing
themselves because they thought their
copy would replace them on the ark oddly
enough though they were actually correct
the copy version will replace the
original on the ark but they believed
that there was a way to prevent this
there isn't because the brain isn't
transferring you it's copying you I've
seen a lot of discourse over this
continuity Theory some love it and
others find it idiotic I think it's
incredible because it's a normal human
reaction Mark and the crew that followed
this continuity Theory were wrong this
continuity thing doesn't exist and
that's never how it worked in the first
place but the actions that resulted from
this Theory are believable and human all
these people are Humanity's Last Hope
and none of them want to be down here
they want to be on the ark so if there's
a chance to be on the ark then they'll
take it they're desperate for a better
life because the one they live in
currently sucks and if they have to kill
themselves to do it then they will
because what's the alternative they're
gonna die anyway but anyone who doesn't
follow through with the suicide might
lose their seat on the arc so depending
on what you choose you either have much
to gain and nothing to lose or nothing
to gain and much to lose that's why I
love this Theory it's still incorrect
but the reasons behind their actions
make sense why not give it a shot what's
the worst that could happen you're wrong
and you die oh well the entire world is
gone it's not like you're gonna be
missing much this facility is where the
dunbat is located but the dunbat is
under quarantine to remove it we need a
security Cipher but only certain
Personnel have the new code and this
leads to one of the most concerning
scenes in this whole game to get the
cipher we need to find a security guard
that was stationed here at pathos 2 but
since most people are dead we can't do
that however Catherine has brain scans
of some of the crew and one of them
branded one just happens to be one of
the crew members who would know the code
so we have to load Brandon's scanner to
the computer and get him to give it to
us this might seem a little odd but
nothing incredibly out of the ordinary
until you look at it from a different
perspective Brandon waking up in this
simulation is the same way that Simon
woke up in pathos 2. this technically
isn't a simulation this is a real person
we're resurrecting a person so we can
get info from them Brandon is smart
though and manages to see through
Catherine's trick the simulation now has
a backup procedure for this which is
that it shuts down the simulation
whenever the person's stress level is
too high to prevent them from going
insane if we fail we can just give it
another try and hope it works no big
deal but once again we're Reviving a
person back to life so if we keep
failing we're basically killing and
Reviving Brandon as many times as it
takes what's even worse is that Simon
and Catherine end up invading his room
to find out more about him so that they
can impersonate his girlfriends that he
feels comfortable in the simulation that
is incredibly [ __ ] up and this is just
one person who knows how many people
Catherine could have done this too
furthermore we also have to consider
Simon he was a legacy scan for close to
90 years and at the time the tech was
not perfect so they likely use Simon as
a test dummy to correct the tech the
same way we're torturing Brennan to give
us the code now Brandon obviously
doesn't know he's dying constantly but
it doesn't make the situation any better
as for Simon who knows how many Simons
have gone through the same thing as
Brandon just to make sure the tech is
still working it's horrifying and
downright inhumane and this whole scene
makes you feel like a complete piece of
[ __ ] the entire way through but with
that horrific scene over with we can now
continue on but we're still not out of
the woods yet once activated the dumb
bat wakes up and starts screaming it
seems like once again the wild put
another brain scan into something but
this time the person immediately
recognized where they were and freaked
out after waking up from the destruction
Simon enters another room next door that
has a device that can scan any material
you put inside of it Simon hops inside
and we discover that he is in another
person's body one thing I and Simon
hadn't considered was how he got into
the suit I was just under the assumption
Simon was put in the suit but it never
occurred to me how that would even be
possible but now we have the answer the
last part of what Catherine said though
is very important having a sound mind
and a sound body Carl would kind of Be A
sound mind in a not sound body it wasn't
complete a little earlier there was a
person who was stuck to a wall just
breathing they would have a sound body
but not really a sound mind Simon was
the perfect mesh of both which is how he
can function normally and probably why
he hasn't gone insane over the course of
the game despite being in a different
body also those people I mentioned a
second ago are actually quite relevant
now that we're about to leave data once
we leave the room we're being stalked by
some creature it seems to be blind
considering I was inches away from it in
a brightly lit hallway and it didn't
kill me and from its design of various
Clues we can piece together that this is
one of the crew called Terry Acres a few
minutes ago when I was discussing what
robot to kill for the cortex chip in
that same area there's a room nearby
that has blood and an eyeball on the
floor as well as some writing in
structure gel Terry Akers was a crew
member at Delta but due to the wow
spreading its structure gel everywhere
the Delta crew needed to relocate to
Theta but Terry wanted to stay back at
Delta however he had a bit desperate
during his isolation and ended up
consuming some structure gel either out
of curiosity or because he ran out of
food this then caused him to go insane
and possibly rip out his eye since the
writing claims that he didn't need them
anymore when he eventually caved in and
requested a transfer some of the crew
came to pick him up to which he lashed
out and stabbed a couple of them when
they weren't looking Terry Akers is the
being that is stalking Simon here in
Theta and is also responsible for a lot
of the crew's current conditions later
Terry ends up capturing Simon and he
sees a dream of him and Ashley again
before he comes back to reality but now
attached to the wall this sticky
substance he was stuck in is the same
substance we see some of the crew
attached to which means that they're all
in some simulation dreaming and thanks
to the wow and the structure gel they're
likely going to be here indefinitely it
is technically preserving Humanity as it
was instructed to do it's just not in
the way anyone would actually find
acceptable Simon manages to escape acres
and enter Omicron but something is off
all the crew's heads are gone well this
has to do with something called a black
box we saw one of these black boxes in a
room way at the beginning of the game
but its design document says that the
black boxes monitor the vital signs of
the crew but these black boxes were
short-circuited by the wow at some point
before Simon arrived a man named Johann
Ross was critically injured and was
carried to Omicron since it was the
nearest station the wow in an attempt to
preserve Humanity tried to resuscitate
Ross but nothing seemed to work so it
ended up getting quite desperate and
using more electromagnetism in order to
revive him but this had the side effect
of also affecting the crew's equipment
including their black boxes though while
managed to save Ross but first some
reason he gained the ability of
telepathy this is how he was able to
communicate with Simon whenever he
appears using this telepathy he was able
to tell some of the crew about alphasite
and how to kill the wow it seems that
the wow had caught on to this plan as
all their heads are missing so it likely
overloaded the black boxes until they
exploded in this facility is a specific
container of the structure gel Simon
needs to get this gel for the power suit
so he can Traverse the abyss but this
structure is also modified as it acts as
a sort of poison for the wow so Ross
wants Simon to travel to side Alpha and
destroy the wow and its hold on the
facility but one step at a time though
we need to actually get the suit first
the only one that seems operational is
sitting in a nearby locker with the body
inside pretty gross but we can assume
that they died in a similar way since
their head is missing once Simon grabs
the necessary pieces he's ready to take
the suit but there's a problem since the
structure gel inside Simon's suit is the
only thing keeping him alive right now
he can't just climb out of the suit and
put another one on so the only option
left is to do another brain scan
but with the most expensive camera in
the world
no Indian stock photos would steal their
souls in this case they'd be right
can't you run a diagnosis or something
what was that
no I it just Why was it still talking it
Catherine why was he still talking
that's how it worse
what do you mean you know it's not magic
you were copied the sleeping Simon in
the seat was copied and now you are here
just like Simon lived on in Toronto God
damn you have two Simons there can't be
two Simons what did you think what
happened that you were gonna take my
mind and put it into another body like a
brain transplant I'm sorry
how messed up this is please I didn't
mean to upset how did you expect me to
react to this [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
disgusting
what's gonna happen to him he'll sleep
for a while
and then what wake up in this [ __ ]
nightmare again all alone
so cruel
I do with him make friends
what if
what if he didn't need to wake up you do
that
I don't know
Simon's not the smartest person in the
world but given how much stress his mind
is under it's understandable why he
can't comprehend what's going on we know
that the brain scans are a copy but
Simon still thinks it's a transfer
that's why he's surprised when two
Simons exist but now we have three
Simons Simon two is now going to be left
to Omicron while Simon 3 continues down
the abyss from what we heard from their
conversation it seems like Simon is very
angry and Catherine is upset because
Simon yelled at her but this ends up
creating a very lonely atmosphere
Catherine is the only person that can
talk to him and losing her makes Simon
and the player feel alone and we can see
this happen for a few seconds when Simon
gets on the climber and heads down the
abyss this is the first time that I had
felt truly alone while playing this game
because of how the Omni tool Works
Catherine can only be talked to when
she's plugged into something so when we
take her with us she can't speak this
would mean that we are technically alone
but the thought that I would eventually
plug her in and talk with her again
clouded my mind long enough to make me
not feel alone and it's that difference
that feels so odd to me I didn't feel
alone when I was actually alone but when
I was with Catherine listening to Simon
talk even though she was right there and
able to speak I actually felt alone it's
a weird feeling the only part of this
conversation between the two that really
bothered me is Simon seeing as they
wrote him this way I guess it's a
positive but his ability to just ignore
what he sees in front of him is
incredible Simon talks about this coin
toss theory of his which is that he
believes that he was lucky and ended up
in the body of the suit rather than
stuck in the chair like Simon too this
is something he just comes up with on
the spot and it makes no sense so even
when the evidence slaps him in the face
Simon still believes that the brain
scans transfer the mind not copy them I
can see how this might be difficult for
someone such as Simon who has no clue
how things work in this world but still
he can be very annoying to listen to
sometimes before we can make it down to
the bottom though Ross interrupts our
ride and says that he'll make
preparations after that Interruption
though we finally make it to the bottom
and head to Tao and if you thought the
Ocean before was terrifying you haven't
seen the half of it this place not only
has a few corpses near the entrance but
it's incredibly dark I'm not sure how
YouTube is going to compress this video
when it's uploaded but it was extreme
dark for me when I was playing most of
what I could see was the light and
that's about it there was the occasional
object outside the cone of the
flashlight that I could see but it
wasn't even worth checking out because
of what goes on down here there are
quite a few deadly fish this far down in
the ocean like that angler fish that
nearly killed me but many of the fish
also seem to have been infected with
structure gel thanks to the wow the fish
here by Nature hide in the shadows and
hate the light so these lights double as
a guide and a safety net for the crew at
one point though the lights disappear so
we'll have to use a robot to help guide
us until it gets Swept Away by this
giant creature there are a couple of
notes that point to this being a heavily
mutated squid that has structure gel
placed inside of it but it really
doesn't matter it's large terrifying and
just knocked out my only light source
however through what I can only imagine
is sheer luck and determination Simon
makes it out of the abyss and into towel
here in the towel mess hall is a lot of
rooms for the crew but also a lot of the
crew in general quite a few of them are
being kept Alive by the wow and are
suffering because of it we can peer into
their heads and listen to some of their
last moments and while most of them will
be relevant in a moment discovering one
of the members of the crew was actually
really gut run punching moment as he
scrolled up on a bed holding a picture
of his son Ross's room is also in here
and we can see the pictures of how the
wow mutated with the help of the
structure gel near the mess hall is the
infirmary and sitting in here is Sarah
lindwall the very last human in the
world we now have the choice of killing
Sarah or let her live we've met a few
characters in similar situations all
just a couple button presses away from
dying if you killed and saved everyone
then your reasons were likely the same
but if you killed and saved people why
what makes Robin Amy Sarah and Simon too
different the game is subconsciously
trying to ask you where you draw the
line is Robin okay to keep alive because
she believes she's on the ark or because
she's a robot or is Robin even a robot
to you because if you thought Carl was
human then Robin has to be too does Amy
deserve to stop suffering because she's
a human and if so what makes her
different from Robin and in the case of
Sarah and Amy what makes them different
they're both human and dying and both
are being kept Alive by some life
support the game wants you to figure out
where and why you draw the line at
certain acts but also wants you to think
about each person you've met and if
either of them is truly alive or human
Soma will never answer this question for
you it's on you to do so that means the
majority of the discussion around these
characters and this game is valid some
may think that murder of any kind is
wrong so killing them is the wrong
answer but some may think the opposite
Soma doesn't want to force you into an
ideal but rather help you find your own
ideals about being human and being alive
and this walking in between all this is
the perfect time to do so walking is a
Mindless task so while I was exploring I
was looking back on all the stuff I'd
done up until this point and thought
about whether or not my actions were the
right choice and during this entire
discussion we've been having we've been
looking at Sarah slowly dying not only
is there the choice itself but also the
consequences of the choice you're free
to leave her after unplugging the life
support but why would you she's the last
human on earth why not stay a bit the
problem though is that both of you don't
want to be here Sarah doesn't want a way
for herself to die and Israel didn't
want to wait for her to die either
neither you nor the person going through
this wanna be here if the person could
pass away immediately that would be
ideal but instead there's those brief
few men minutes where time seems to slow
down to a crawl and you're just waiting
for it to be over so the person dying no
longer has to suffer and you no longer
have to stare and watch their life
slowly drain from their body this
segment with Sarah is just two whole
minutes of waiting she at least lightens
the mood of it by telling a story but it
doesn't make things any better sitting
next to Sarah is the ark and now we can
take it to the final station Phi and
launch it into space I wanted to hold
off on this information because like I
said most of the game sprinkles a lot of
it throughout the entire run time but if
we recall from our first conversation
with Catherine she says that she wanted
to send the ark into space but it never
made it well once we approached the
final station Phi we can see Catherine's
body and uncover what happened Catherine
was killed over a disagreement between
her and Ian the one from the interview
he believed that the ark wouldn't
survive in space because of how much
debris there was out there and he wanted
to make sure it was safe before they
launched it since they only have one
shot it's a little odd and it's still
something I'm confused about because Ian
clearly expressed his interest in the
project but he backs out last moment I
get where he's coming from I know he
doesn't want the ark to be destroyed by
the space debris but who who cares it's
the end of the world and they probably
won't get another chance again the one
thing I really did like about this
discovery though is that you can
actually figure this out the moment you
enter Phi on a computer is a staff list
of all the crew who came and left the
station five people all entered on
December 25th and four left the same day
with Catherine being the only one who
didn't leave most of Soma's story has
really been a show don't tell kind of
method the only time it deviates from
this is when something important is
happening like when Simon was being
copied and the games he's fit to explain
what's going on even though we could
infer what happened it's better that the
game explains it just in case people are
confused because it's that important but
besides that most of it is left for the
player to uncover it's never explained
what happened at Omicron with the
Headless crew unless you put all the
pieces together and I really appreciated
that it makes the discovery feel more
rewarding because you're figuring it out
on your own before we can make it to Phi
though we need to make sure the arc gets
in its casing and to do that we'll need
to take another momentary Ross
Interruption but this time it takes us
to the center of the alpha site where
the wow is stationed since Simon has the
toxic structure gel from Omicron in his
suit all he has to do is push his hand
inside just like we've done numerous
times before this time though Simon has
his hand taken and bitten off by the wow
it's still infected with the poison so
it seems like everything is still
working but Ross says that to eliminate
the wow it must remove everything it
created including us Ross sadly isn't
going to get the opportunity to do so as
the giant squid comes back and saves Us
by eating him oddly enough you don't
actually have to do this right before
you touch the wow you can see a yellow
button by a door and by the game's logic
up until this point that means it's an
unlocked door that hasn't been open yet
if you manage to catch that before
putting your arm in the wow you can just
walk away Ross will obviously try to
stop you but he gets killed anyway the
only noticeable change between the two
is that Simon's hand will be gone for
the remainder of the game and you'll be
constantly reminded of that decision
whenever you climb any ladders on the
station after placing the arc on the
Space Gun Simon and Catherine now wait
for the countdown to begin Simon of
course is worried because Catherine
promised that they would do brain skin
so they can get on the ark Catherine
however planned ahead and has it rigged
up so that both will happen at the same
time Simon no longer has to worry and is
now eager to get scanned to get on the
arc but
well I think we know where this is going
to
be
still we're still here Catherine
Catherine from here what the hell
happened what went wrong nothing
they're out there Among the Stars we're
here
no
we were getting on the ark I saw it it
finished loading just before it launched
yeah I saw then why are we still here
Simon I can't keep telling you how it
works you won't listen you know why
we're here you were copied onto the ark
you just didn't carry over you lost the
coin toss we both did just like Simon
and Elmer Khan just like the man who
died in Toronto 100 years ago
[ __ ] we came all this way we
launched the ark I know it sucks but our
copies are up there Catherine and Simon
are both safe on the ark be happy for
them are you crazy we're gonna die down
here with those [ __ ] living at large
on a spaceship they're not us they're
not us I'm sorry you feel that way Simon
I'm proud of what we did make sure that
something of the hundreds of thousands
of years of human history survives that
something lives on
oh [ __ ] this [ __ ]
[ __ ] this [ __ ] you [ __ ] you Catherine
you lied and I believed in you I trusted
you you said we're getting all the
[ __ ] Ark we are on the argue idiot I
didn't lie I can't be responsible for
your goddamn ignorance [ __ ]
Catherine
please don't leave me alone
Catherine
Catherine
obviously it still hasn't clicked for
Simon that he was going to be copied and
not transferred Catherine has tried to
explain this to him numerous times and
he still didn't get it she even tried to
make Simon understand by explaining it
with the coin toss method that he came
up with but as we know that's not even a
real thing she just tried to explain it
in a way that would make sense to him
since his ignorance has reached levels I
have never seen achieved before but he
still doesn't get it Civic will about
Simon and his intelligence it's hard not
to feel bad about his current situation
he's trapped at the bottom of the ocean
with all the lights and power off there
doesn't seem to be a way for him to
leave the facility since everything is
off so Simon is going to have to find a
way to kill himself if he wants to
escape this nightmare it's almost ironic
in a way if you ended up actually saving
Simon too earlier because you as Simon 3
kept Simon to alive at Omicron and
though the game is forcing Simon 3 to be
stuck here with him speaking of Simon
too you might be wondering what happened
to our choices and to that I say who
cares it's over
that's not a joke or anything that's
pretty much what the game says None of
the people we killed or saved changed
anything the only meaningful change in
this game was the wow and it's only
because you have to stare at your lost
arm for an hour if you wanted to kill it
destroying the wow or not doesn't change
anything killing Simon 2 Amy Robin and
Sarah change nothing so many games give
the player a consequence for their
choices some was only consequences and
arm the Earth is gone and humanity is
dead so what would be the consequences
of our choices none of them are going to
see that Arc but that doesn't mean we
can't we briefly take control of Simon 4
and he believes he won Catherine knows
better but won't say anything Simon 4
has no idea that Simon 3 is still down
there in the bottom of the ocean if
that's confusing allow me to provide an
example copying or cloning yourself
means that you and your clone are the
exact same person up until the Clone was
created so if you knew what two plus two
was before the scan the Clone would know
too but if you didn't know what that was
and only learned it after creating the
Clone only you would know that
information since it was after the Clone
was created Simon's brain was scanned
before he realized he was only going to
be copied and not transferred and since
this new Simon Simon 4 is the same as
Simon 3 sitting in the chair at that
exact moment he doesn't know Simon 3
exists and believes he won the coin toss
that's kind of horrifying if you think
about it and I doubt Catherine would
have told Simon for what happened or who
would have gone insane knowing he just
doomed his older self the best part
about the arc though is that the survey
Returns the survey is easily one of the
best place devices in this game the
first is placed right when the player
learns the truth about the world and the
second is after the player learns the
truth about the game this survey was
never for Simon or the people of the Ark
it was just made that way so that it
fits him with the lore this survey is
actually for the player in both surveys
I try to answer as honestly as I could
in the first one I was hopeful
optimistic I was obviously in a scary
dark place but there was still hope I
was with Simon and Catherine and we are
going to save the ark but now that I'm
on the ark I wasn't happy I left Simon
behind and I couldn't accept that yeah
Simon 4 is still Simon 3 but that's not
my Simon even though Simon 3 and 4 are
literally the same person Simon fourfeld
alien to me because they're two
different people it felt like I had two
different relationships with them and
that's the weird part Simon 3 and 4 are
the same person so I shouldn't feel sad
the example I used earlier translates to
this Simon III copied himself and made
Simon four which means that Simon 4 went
through everything the others did but
just went a little bit further so
because of this I really shouldn't feel
bad because Simon made it I got him on
the ark but this Simon feels different
to me I grew a connection with the Simon
2 and 3 not Simon four despite
technically being him since the start of
the game even though I had succeeded I
still couldn't help but feel like I
betrayed Simon and at the last moment
instead of staying behind I went on the
ark without him so when I answered the
survey I felt sad I wanted Simon 3 here
with me not Simon four but at the end of
the survey it asks would you rather be
removed from the project and accept
death
I answered no even though Simon III was
left behind I wasn't going to join him
is that selfish of me probably but I'm
human even though Simon 3 lost I have
won is that greedy of me probably but
I'm human Soma brings out all the human
emotions that we have and never does
anything with them just lets us sit with
them and let us ask the questions
ourselves so no I don't want to die I
want to be in the ark even if that means
I leave Simon through behind because on
the ark I'm alive and being alive is a
part of Being Human
thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video please be sure
to leave a like if you're watching this
on release then just a reminder this is
the first video I plan to make for our
October horror themed month if you want
to know more about it though check out
the community tab here on the channel
regardless I hope you enjoyed Soma
because I sure did like the video If you
enjoyed And subscribe if you're new as
always thank you to my returning viewers
for coming back to another video and
take care everyone
goodbye
foreign
[Music]